okay so we are doing Socrates and Plato
today um last class we did Greek Theater
and remember I said that iselis sopes
and Ides they're really profits of
democracy uh they see themselves as
teachers who teach Athenians how to
practice uh democracy we also said that
there are three major benefits to
democracy the first major benefit is uh
kings are bad okay uh King Kings have
hubris and hubis creates all sorts of
problems so remember in the play
intey um by Sophocles the king Creon
sentences Integrity To Death even though
it was unjust and that was because of
hubris second ma major benefit of
democracy is it is a gift from from the
gods that teaches citizens individual
responsibility okay so remember that Ina
ises told us that democracy is a gift
from Athena in order to uh promote
Justice and Truth in the world and the
third ma major benefit is democracy is
really the best way to promote Justice
and Truth in the world if citizens um
come together and they deliberate and
act um with um in good faith then the
world will be a better place okay so
that is the argument from the play
rights of Athens now obviously there are
people who disagree with this
perspective and one of the most famous
opponents of democracy is
Socrates
Socrates um lived during the time of the
Golden Age of Pericles in Athens and he
was a very vocal opponent of democracy
for the following reason in order to
practice democracy properly people need
to access the truth but to access the
truth you need to have
reason and his argument was that most
people are not capable of exercising
reason in their thinking okay and to
prove this every day he would be sing
outside the Agora which is the
marketplace of Athens and this is where
everyone came together and he would
spend all day arguing with people in
something call achronic dialogue
and showing the
flaws in your reasoning okay showing you
why you don't really understand the
world when you think you do okay trying
to prove that um you are ignorant okay
so let me give you a demonstration of
what sakes did okay so give me a
statement that is
fundamentally and inherently
true give me a statement that that you
think is fundamentally and inherently
true
the Earth is a spear right the Earth is
a
spear and so this is a segement that we
think is true right and so what Socrates
would do is he would slowly and meth
methodologically uh expose the flaws in
this statement okay so the first
question for you
is what is a sphere
explain what a spear
is okay so a threedimensional round
shaped entity okay
um and give me an example of a
spear a ball right so you're saying the
the Earth is like a ball is that correct
it's it's all
around okay and how do you know
the statement is true who told you
this I mean you can know a ball is a
spear because you hold it in your hand
right but you're not a God you don't
hold the Earth in your hand so how do
you know it's
true anyway I can go on like this
obviously for a very long time and so
this what socres did this is what it
called a psychotic dialogue and actually
we still use this in many different
places like for example law school so in
American law schools if you have if you
ever make the stupid mistake of ever
applying to law school and you get into
law school uh they will uh teach you
using the psychotic dialogue okay but
but the idea is to show the flaws in
your reasoning and obviously if you get
an argument with Socrates you come out
as a very mad person okay so the
reputation of Socrates in Athens during
this time was he was either a you could
see him as a Bly okay he was
intellectual bully or he was a clown or
the most common understanding of
Socrates was he was a trickster okay he
tricked you into making statements that
were illogical because fundamentally
language um does not capture the truth
okay language is just a convention we
have to in order for us to communicate
but it's not meant to reflect reality
okay and Socrates was exposing the fun
fundamental
flaws in our language
system um so any questions about this so
far all right so to give you a sense of
how Athenians thought about Socrates at
that time let me describe to you a play
by Aristophanes okay
Aristophanes um Aristophanes was a very
famous satus in
Athens and he made fun of all the very
famous individuals of Athens including
Pericles who as we said was the defacto
king of Athens at this time but also
Cleon who replaced uh um Pericles as the
uh leader of Athens he also made for fun
of Socrates
okay and the play uh was produced in
423 BCE and the play was called the
clouds so let me first explain the plot
of the clouds and then we will interpret
what it meant okay so in the clouds this
is Athenian farmer a normal Citizen and
he's he's in a lot of trouble because
his wife spends a lot of money so he
owes a lot of money to creditors and his
creditors are banging at the door and
demanding their money back so he comes
up this with this plan to get rid of his
debts there's a school called a
thinkery okay and it's run by a man
named
the thinkery proposes to teach you
reason logic truth so that you can go
and deceive drawers okay you can
basically go and manipulate people and
deceive them in a in a trial to get out
of your debts so he wants to send his
son to the thinkery to learn how to lie
to juries his son who is a Playboy
refuses because he says that Socrates
he's a chief he's a liar he's a fraud I
refuse to go the man decides to check
out the thinkery by himself he goes in
and he sees
Socrates okay hanging from a basket from
the
ceiling and the man's curious like what
are you doing up there and Socrates says
well from up here I have a clearer and
higher vision of the world I can access
truth better also from here I can draw
inspiration from the clouds who are the
true gods okay not Zeus not Heracles the
clouds are the true gods and they're the
ones who give me inspiration to come up
with all these brilant ideas okay so the
man in Socrates has they have a very
long conversation and he's completely
convinced Socrates is a sage okay he's a
philosopher he runs back and he tells
his son you must go enroll in the
thinkery and learn from Socrates okay so
the man the son decides this is the path
of leas resistance he goes to the
thinkery he becomes saulty student
meanwhile uh the man's creditors are
banging at the door and and saying to
him where is my
money and the man says the man is now
going to use all the tricks that socres
taught him okay so what he says is I
don't owe you any money and then the
Creditor says you swore by zoos that you
would pay me back the man said says oh
guess what Zeus doesn't exist okay he's
not a God so I swore an oath to nothing
therefore I I owe you nothing the
creditors the Creditor obviously gets
angry and he leaves okay now the son
comes
back and he and the first thing he does
is start beating his father and the
father is like why are you beating me
son and then the son says Socrates
taught me to beat you and the father's
like what he didn't why is he teaching
you that and the son says he taught me
Justice now when I was young did you
beat
me the father says yes of course I beat
you because you were a naughty boy and
then the son says therefore I can now
beat you because you're a naughty person
for refusing to pay back your creditors
okay the man gets very angry and he
decides to go burn down the thinkery
with ses inside it okay and that's how
the play end
now um this is not a great play okay
this is not a famous play of Greece but
it tells you what Athenians thought of
Socrates at this time
okay um and it shows us that Athenians
didn't think much of Socrates he
worships the clouds right which is
nothing so what they're saying is
Socrates makes things out of fer okay
he's just a fraud he's a manipulator
he's is a liar but SES did have a lot of
fans specifically people who really
hated democracy and so the people who
really really hated democracy were the
children of the rich okay these were
Aristocrats uh Born Into the wealthiest
most noble aristoc aristocratic families
of Athens who hated the fact that the
normal people thought they were their
equals okay so what SES did was he
taught them basically mental or
linguistic kung fu right to go beat up
these commoners who dare to think
they're equals one one of the most
famous uh the most famous of Sak
students included Plato who we all
know but also um alab 8es who was one of
the um wealthiest members of Athenian
society and he actually became leader of
Athens as well
okay
so um Socrates had his fans um and and
because Athens were such a wealthy and
open and Toler Society they allowed
Socrates to basically do whatever he
wanted
okay until
BC this was the
year that uh Athens lost the pelian war
to Sparta okay and when Athens lost the
war Sparta did not burn Athens down
Sparta had the right to burn Athens down
but it did not okay okay instead Athens
imposed a dictatorship called the 30
tyrants and the 30 tyrants came from the
wealthiest uh families of Athens who
also happened to be students of Socrates
okay soes did not actually participate
in a tyranny okay SES refused to
participate in the Tyranny but there
were many of these tyrants who were soy
students and they were terrible people
they killed at least 5% of of the
Athenian uh population they stole uh a
lot of wealth and they were so terrible
that ultimately the aan people revolted
against them and reinstalled their
democracy
okay so
um when the de when the Tyran was
overthrown um the 30 tyrants were
exiled H but most people were given
clemency okay they were forgiven if they
participated in the
regime then what happens next is very
strange in
BCE Socrates is put on trial remember
this is after the democracy is rein
reinstated and this is when uh people
who part particip participated in the
Tyranny were forgiven okay but in 399
BCE SES was put on trial and he was put
on trial and charged with two crimes the
the first is
impiety okay which basically means he
was insulting the gods of Athens
including Zeus which is what he did in
the play clouds okay um the second is
corrupting the Youth of Athens okay
basically Mis educating the Youth of
Athens which is also what he did in the
clouds okay so it almost seems like this
entire trial was a cruel joke put on by
the people of Athens to teach Socrates a
lesson okay does that make
sense so um the people of Athens
expected SES to
apologize uh make some jokes be be funny
and then all forgiven right during the
trial Socrates refused to defend himself
what he said was
this I am not a good speaker I am bad
with words I'm just a poor person okay
who comes from a poor family who spends
every day seeking out the truth I spend
all my time seeking out the truth
thinking about the truth that I have no
time to practice rhetoric I'm not good
with words also I should not have to
defend myself because you're all capable
of reason you're all capable of logic
therefore if you just think for yourself
you will realize I'm not guilty I have
abs nothing I had absolutely nothing to
do with the 30 tyrants I spent all my
life trying to help Athens therefore if
you're stupid you will vote me guilty if
you're stupid there's nothing I can do
about it okay so obviously the jury was
insulted by his speech and they voted
out of 500 people 280 to 220 to they
voted that he is guilty okay they
declared he was guilty of these two
charges now as you can see it's still a
pretty clo close vote okay I mean
Socrates was basically being a jerk
during a trial and they still they put
they voted him guilty but it was a
pretty close trial 280 to 220 now the
second part of the trial is if you are
found
guilty um they have to figure out what
your punishment is okay so they the jury
asked Sak to propose a punishment for
his crimes and then what Sak said was
you have found me guilty and is and the
reason why you found me guilty is
because I speak the truth I a god Godly
okay
gadfly I go around and I point out the
nasty truths of Athenian Society I put a
mirror to your face and I show you your
warts your pimples your
ugliness therefore you hate me but what
I've been doing all my life has been for
the good and better of Athens I'm a
public servant I am the most selfless
public
servant okay because because I speak the
truth and by showing the truth I make
you a better person therefore I think a
just punishment would be a pension okay
you guys should pay me to retire in
peace but you know what I'm in generous
and forgiving individual therefore if
you don't want to give me a pension I
will understand therefore I am willing
to pay a small fine okay I I'll pay a
fine okay and then we're good how about
that and and again the Athan jurors were
pissed off right so they voted to
condemn him to death by Ching Hemlock
okay they basically gave him the death
penalty after they did so they came to
realize that they were perhaps tricked
by Socrates okay Socrates was 70 years
old um that's a that's very old for back
then okay 70 years years old was
probably the age limit uh back then he
really didn't have much to live
for and here was the opportunity for
socres to be a mar for the truth right
all his life he's been trying to
convince people democracy does not work
because people are incapable of
reasoning out the truth and what this
trial shows us is he was correct right
does that make sense so in in many ways
you can make the argument that for
Socrates this tribe was a type of
performance
art he was a performance artist okay and
so the people of Athens realized
that they were probably tricked and they
were trying to get out of uh condemning
SES to death but SES
insisted and and it came to a point
where sakes was was just left alone and
he had to demand to be given Hemlock and
he had and he had to administr the
hemlock by himself and so when he drank
it he died okay now
um after his death sakes remained an
extremely controversial individual in
Athens and he had a student
Plato who was maybe 28 29 at the time
his mentor died okay and he loved
Socrates
and he commit the rest of his life to uh
restoring and Redeeming the reputation
of Socrates so when he was 40 years old
he founded a school called the
economy okay which was inspired by the
vision of Socrates as a philosopher who
sought the truth in
375 BCE he wrote a book called The
Republic and the Republic is uh the most
famous of Plato's work it is arguably
the greatest work of Western philosophy
and many today considered uh the
Republic the greatest book ever written
okay there are people in this world who
read the Republic and it forever
transforms the way they see the world
okay it's a life transforming event to
read the Republic and next semester we
will actually read the Republic together
okay but let me give you a quick
introduction to The Republic so in the
Republic uh there's a very famous
metaphor and it's called allegory of the
cave and this is really the most
famous allegory or metaphor or analogy
in Western thought okay by far nothing
comes second to this so um before I
start the allegory of the cave are there
any questions so far about what I've
discussed anything
unclear anything you would like to
question or doubt or argue with before I
continue with the algo of the
cave okay clear so far all right so this
is the allegory imagine a cave deep
under the Earth okay there's a cave now
in this cave at the back there's a a
large fire that shines light on this
into this cave okay there are these
prisoners who are chained to the floor
and they're chained so that they cannot
move their necks they can't move around
okay they can't move the only thing they
can do is steer at a wall in front of
them that's the only thing they can do
okay now there are these people behind
them who are like puppeteers they hold
up uh cardboard pictures of like maybe
like rats and birds okay and the fire
will project the these images onto the
wall and so these people who again
cannot move around and they can only see
the wall in front of them they come to
think that this wall is the truth it's
the only reality that exists and they
start naming
things that they see and that creates
language and they like to play games and
try to figure out who can create the
best language okay and then they give
Awards to the people who create the best
language who are playwrights right um
okay so what play is saying is that we
may honor art and poetry and drama but
they're all
lies okay now one day for whatever
reason we don't know why but one man
finds his chains are loosened and he's
able to get up okay he swims around he
sees a light coming from the top so he's
curious and he climbs all the way to the
top and he's now outside in the Free
World okay and it's painful because his
eyes are not trained to see the sunlight
okay so the sunlight it's like burning
him okay it's like burning him alive and
so at first all he's all he's doing is
St at the ground and see he's seeing
reflections in the pawn in the pool but
then he slowly accoma himself to the
sunlight and he starts to see the world
around him and it's beautiful okay but
it's so beautiful that is beyond
language he doesn't have the language to
describe this world that he's in okay
this is beyond language then
finally he develops the courage to stare
up in the sky and he sees the sun okay
the
son and he is Amazed by how the Sun is
the source of all life and now for the
first time he fully understands the
truth of the
world okay and when he does he is seized
by
regret because he remembers he has all
these
friends who are still trapped and in
prison in the cave and he pi them so he
swears that he will even though he loves
where he is he will still Venture back
into the cave in order to show people
the truth of the world and to tell them
that you've been living a lie all your
life okay so he goes back into the cave
now remember his eyes are now accustomed
to sunlight so in the cave it's all dark
so he stumbles around he stumbles around
he falls and he hurts himself okay and
then he goes and talks to the prisoners
and say and tells them hey I've been to
the outside world I've been to the
sunlight I know what truth is and then
they're like can you describe to us what
it's like then and he can't do it okay
and then they're like tell us what you
see on the wall and because he's been so
accustom to the truth he can no longer
use human language to describe anything
okay and so the people are convinced
utterly convinced he's an idiot he's
insane he's a
clown and so they refuse to follow him
and at some point because he
insists on revealing the truth to them
they kill
him okay that's Alo to the cave okay and
you will remember this allegory for the
rest of your life now this allegory is
powerful for three reasons okay and I I
want you to remember these three reasons
because we will go into them later on in
the course the first reason
is who's the man who um goes out in the
sunlight and sees the truth it's
obviously Socrates right so with this
allegory Plato redeems the reputation of
Socrates right because remember before
Socrates was despised he was laughed at
by the Athenians and what does allegory
saying is that's because Socrates is a
philosopher of the truth okay and people
cannot deal with the truth so that's why
today we celebrate Socrates as the
greatest philosopher whoever lived not
only that but we consider him the first
philosopher even though he was not the
first philosopher okay right so that's
the power of the allegory of the cave
this image forever transforms the way
Humanity understands and perceives
socres that's the first thing second
thing is this allegory becomes so
powerful that in the
imagination of Christians Socrates
becomes Jesus
right does that make
sense Socrates is Jesus for Christians
because Jesus was God and he came down
to our world in order to speak the truth
and because we feared the truth we
killed
him
okay so for Christians aligo the of the
cave is really the story of Jesus as
well another martyr for the truth but
and the last thing is this allegory the
cave becomes the framework for
Christianity
okay it becomes intellectual framework
for the religion of of Christianity so
let let me show you how Okay so this is
an allegory and behind the allegory
there is an understanding of reality of
philosophy a religion okay so here is
the platonic understanding of the world
there's something call the the
form of the
good okay and the obviously the um met
for would be the sun okay and the form
of the good is a source of everything
okay it's a source of all truth it is
the truth it's called the form of the
good and emanating from the form of the
good are Concepts and ideals that
structure the universe and they
are uh
reason
Beauty and truth and Justice okay and
that there are others okay okay but
these are the main ones reason truth
beauty and Justice this they emanate
from the form of the good okay and then
emanating from these concepts are these
forms that are perfect okay so for
example maybe the perfect horse which
represents Beauty okay or the perfect
woman who represents Justice and Beauty
as well okay but this all
Perfection and from this higher world
comes our the Lesser world the reality
we live in so everything that we we see
here everything that we are here is only
an imitation a
shadow of this world okay does that make
sense imitation so there there are
horses but these horses are just copies
of that perfect horse up
there okay so the major difference is in
this world this world is eternal it has
always existed and it will it will
always exist it's Eternal second is it
is IM um immutable immunal just means it
will never change okay because and the
reason why is it's
perfect okay so these are three distin
qualities of this higher
World Eternal Immaculate and perfect and
everything down here is basically the
complete opposite okay we will all die
we all feel feel pain but up there no
one feels any pain no one dies it's all
perfect okay does that make sense guess
what guys what is this this is a
Christian Universe right this is
God this is
heaven this is
Earth okay does it make sense this is
the allegory of the cave and you can see
how it does these three things it
redeems the reputation of Socrates it
gives Christians understanding of
Jesus and it becomes the framework from
which Christians will build their
understanding of the world it becomes
the basis of the Christian
religion okay so Plato is the real
founder of the Christian religion not
Jesus
okay and we will go more into this we we
when we discuss
Christianity in the future all right
any
questions you you look
confused just ask any question let's
let's start having having discussion
okay because because I I know this is a
lot let's try to unpack it
okay
yep oh great okay the Republic
okay okay so um the Republic isn't
really about the algo of the cave okay
the Alo the cave actually appears in the
Republic the Republic
itself so Plato is trying to answer the
question what is a good
Society okay what is a good Society
that's a question he's trying to answer
because it's clearly not democracy
because democracy kills Socrates okay so
it's clearly not democracy so what makes
a good Society and the answer is it's a
society that's based on
Justice okay it's a it's a society
that's based on justice but then what is
Justice it's
truth
okay but then what's truth well truth is
the form of the good then what's form of
the good it's it is the thing that
philosophers can access for their own
reasoning right therefore a good Society
is one that is ruled by philosopher
Kings because you're the only ones who
can access the truth okay and this
Society that's perfect he calls the
Republic that's why it's called the
Republic the Republic and we'll read
this again next semester is it's really
trying to figure out what makes a good
Society okay and to further his argument
uh Plato uses the allegory of the cave
and and like I like listen 50 years from
now you will still remember the Alo
decade maybe you won remember uh the CH
sakes or anything else you've learned in
this class but you will definitely
remember the allegory of the cave okay
because it's embedded first of all it's
a beautiful metaphor but it's also
embedded in our society
okay so uh does that answer your
question uh Echo okay do you have more
questions
all right um something else I want to
explain is
okay um some some might be interested as
to why Plato is considered the greatest
philosoph of all time okay all right so
um it's not because he's the bass all
right it's not because he's the bass um
I would say there are three good reasons
why he's so influential today the first
is
Plato the way he writes it's Unique and
original to him Plato originally trained
as a playwright okay so he wanted to be
issist he wanted to be Sophocles yides
because every wanted everyone wanted to
be um a playwright in Athens it was the
highest
honor um so he he he learned the art of
dialogue okay because dialogue is the
basis for theater and so what he did
that was Innovative and no one did this
before was he basically took the
dialogue of the stage and he transferred
onto the page so when you read PL it's
actually a lot of fun okay because
because because it's basically Socrates
is main character having arguments and
conversations with other people so in
terms of um readability Plato is
definitely probably the most one of the
most readable
philosophers okay he's definitely the
most readable famous philosopher uh
later on the semester we will read we
will talk about Emanuel Kant and uh
Hegel and they are not readable okay
they're just not but Plato anyone can
read Plato and enjoy Plato okay so his
readability um the orig origin
originality of his writing is one really
good reason why uh he uh remains so
popular today second is
um he is extremely anti uh
Democratic okay his thinking is because
like remember the most traumatic event
in his life was the death of his mentor
Socrates and so it's Athan democracy who
killed his mentor so he passionately
hates
democracy okay well you know who else
democracy Kings hate democracy and
throughout most of human history Kings
rule the rule the world right so what's
amazing about Plato is he's the
only writer in human history who has
been read continuously for 2,000 years
does that make sense we lost Homer for a
bit uh we lost uh the play rights ises
sopes Andes for a long time but Plato
has always been read
continuously and he's been the most and
as a result because it's easy to access
Plato he's become the most influential
philosopher of all
time okay does that make
sense and Third of all uh what was his
Academy okay and the academy in Athens
at that time it's like Harvard right or
Oxford today it's a place where all the
elite children went okay so his students
were the most powerful people in the
world basically and his most famous
student was
Aristotle and as we will discuss uh in
future classes Aristotle is the one who
basically um packaged and promoted Greek
culture and Plato became a very
important individual in in in the
spreading of Greek culture in fact he
was basically uh the main
hero uh in this process okay so does
that make sense all
right feel free to argue with me by the
way I mean like like if you feel I've
said anything controversial or you
disagree with let me know and I will
rebut we we can have a psychotic
dialogue
okay any more
questions ask a question
okay okay that's a br question okay what
are the influences of PlayDoh okay so
you can make the argument that that um
shes was not that much of an
intellectual influence on Plato and the
reason why is remember Socrates question
your wisdom but he himself did not
propose any of his own theories okay
proposal right so um what we know is
this first of all um during this time
this was the Golden Age of Greek
philosophy right you had lots of
philosophers in different Poes different
places proposing all these wonderful
theories so PL definitely had access to
them plus they were all all friends okay
and we also know this world of Greek
thought was heavily influenced by Egypt
right because Egypt was really the
epicenter of uh learning and philosophy
at this time and Egypt was actually very
close
to um to Greece also uh Mesopotamia
right uh the uh the Persians okay so um
399 BC Socrates dies and then PL spend
the next 12 years Trav traveling around
the world and while he's traveling he's
absorbing lots of different philosophy
okay so um look we don't have access to
Egyptian sources right so we don't
know
um uh what sources would influence Plato
but we know the Egyptians heavily
influenced the Greeks so so we can make
the assumption that the Egyptians were
heavy influence on Plato as well as uh
Mesopotamia as well as the other Greek
philosophers like Pythagoras and
democratus and um so so what's really
important is um Athens at this time was
not an isolated Society it was part of a
larger intellectual landscape that and a
lot of these places had richer
intellectual histories than Athens okay
Egypt definitely uh
Mesopotamia
okay so does that answer your question
the answer is we don't know
and the reason again is most of this is
loss to us right I I'm sure there were
philosophers at this at this time who
were the equal of Plato in terms of
originality okay but we don't know who
these people were because remember
censorship sensorship it's not really
just about changing the past it's also
about uh eliminating most of the past
right okay
it was it was very common it was very
common it was it was very common for
Greeks to think they should rule the
world was just very common so Plato
himself um actually went to a place
called
Syracuse um Syracuse is a city um on the
island of Sicily it's very prosperous
and the king of CIS of ccus invited
Plato to come counsel him on how to be a
tyrant a good Tyrant right he wanted to
be like a philosopher king then Plato
basically said to him well you should
let me be the king and then you will
have a philosopher king and of course
the king of SES didn't like this idea so
he uh almost killed Plato okay but Plato
had very again Plato has very wealthy
friends and and he was very rich himself
so he basically Ransom his way out of
Syracuse so as a
politician as a um practitioner of De of
like philosophy sorry as a practitioner
of his philosophy he's terrible okay
right he tried his philosophy in
Syracuse didn't work out pissed off a
lot of people
okay but um everyone everyone wanted to
be u a philosopher king um um okay any
more
questions okay so um next class we will
do um the rise of
Macedonia okay so remember these are
ideas that are being incubated in Athens
and in gree at this time but ultim these
ideas conquer the world right uh Greek
Theater Greek philosophy spread all
around the world and the main reason is
Macedonia uh the main reason are two
individuals Philip II of Macedonia and
Alexander the Great okay who together
will create the helenistic helenistic
Empire and this is why Greek culture
will spread around the world and become
the basis of Western Civilization
but